We've seen graphs involving
boys and girls and connections
between them in the context
of our sexual demographics
calculation and study.
A similar problem
comes up in terms
of what I call stable
matching, which is again
the issue of matching up boys
and girls in a special way
according to some constraints.
It turns out to have a
lot of applications which
we'll discuss toward the end.
Let's just look at
what the problem is.
The setup is that there's some
number of boys, in this case 5,
1 through 5, and an equal number
of girls labeled A through E.
And each of the boys has
a ranking of the girls.
Different rankings,
because different boys
have different preferences.
And likewise, the girls
have rankings of the boys.
Different girls have
different preferences.
So here, girl A likes boy 3
best and boy 5 second best,
and boy 1 likes girls C
best and girl D least.
So the problem,
basically, is that we
want to get all the boys
married to all the girls.
We want to form 5 monogamous
bisexual marriages, a boy
and a girl, and we'd
like, in some vague way,
to acknowledge these preferences
and satisfy as many as we can.
I'll be more specific
about that in a minute.
But let's just
play with that idea
of trying to accommodate
people's preferences.
So one way to do it
is let's just decide,
well, we'll favor
the boys this time.
Let's try a greedy
strategy for the boys.
Let's just look at
the boy preferences.
And a greedy strategy
means I'm going
to try to give each boy the
best possible choice that he
can make.
So I'm going to
start off by deciding
that let's let boy 1 have
his first choice, girl
C. I'm going to marry them off.
And once I've married
them off, I'll just
stop considering 1 and C. And
now I have a reduced problem.
I have four remaining boys
and four remaining girls.
And proceeding in this
way-- greedy way for boys--
I'm going to now give boy 2
his next choice that remains,
namely girl A. And
I'll marry them off.
And again, now 2 and A can be
eliminated from consideration.
I continue in this
way and I wind up
with this set of five
marriages ending with boy 5
married to girl E.
OK.
Now if we look at
this set of marriages,
there's a problem
which motivates
the whole stable marriage
problem that we're
going to be examining.
Namely, we've married off boy
1 to his first choice, girl C.
He should be happy,
but she may not be.
And we've also married
off boy 4 to girl B.
Now a difficulty here is that
if you look at the preferences,
girl C actually is more
desirable to boy 4 than girl B.
Girl C, or boy 4, likes
somebody else's wife
better than his own.
And what makes it really bad is
that girl C, the other person's
wife, likes boy 4
better than her husband.
Each of them would be better
off if they ran off together.
They are, whether
they do or not,
they certainly are under
tremendous pressure.
It makes this set of
marriages unstable.
So they're called
a rogue couple.
When you have in
a set of marriages
a boy and a girl who
prefer each other
over their current
spouses, they are
said to be a rogue couple
and a source of instability.
So the stable
marriage problem is
let's see if we can get
everybody married off
and have no rogue couples.
It'll be a stable
set of marriages.
Now people may not
be happy, but it
doesn't matter
because they'll never
find anybody else that is
unhappy in the same way that
would be willing to run off
with them and make them happier.
So it's stable.
And it turns out
that there always
is a way to find a
stable set of marriages.
A couple of ways.
But why don't we just
play with the idea.
Here is display of
those preferences again
and you can stop the video and
fiddle with a piece of paper
and see if you can come up
with a stable set of marriages
between the boys and girls.
We used to do this in
class in real time.
We would give five
different boys
a chart of preferences
of girls, and we'd
give the five different girls
a chart of preferences of boys.
They were not supposed
to tell each other what
their preferences
were, but the girls
were supposed to be interviewing
the boys and the boys
interviewing the girls
simultaneously in a parallel,
and try to agree to
get married and see
whether the set of marriages
that they wound up with
were stable.
Most of the time they
actually did wind up
with a stable set of
marriages, but not always.
Just an amusing exercise.
And it does illustrate
something about the fact
that the procedures that we're
going to be going through
to find stable marriages
work very nicely if you
choose to do them in parallel.
Anyway, there are, it turns out,
two sets of stable marriages
that we can find in this
particular set of preferences.
The simplest one to
understand is all the girls
get their first choice.
It so happens, if you look at
that chart, all of the girls
have different
first choice boys.
If we simply give them
their first choice,
no girl is going to be tempted
to be part of a rogue couple
because she's got
her first choice.
It's absolutely stable.
But of course, that's a
very special circumstance.
It would be unusual that all
the girls' first choices were
different, or likewise,
it would be unusual
if all the boys' first
choices were different.
But if they were,
then you instantly
get a stable set of marriages.
There's another stable set
that's not quite so obvious.
And you can check that
all of these pairs
have no instability.
There's no rogue couples in here
when I marry 5 to A and 1 to E.
This is a so-called "boy
optimal" set of marriages.
It turns out that in
this set of marriages,
every boy gets the
best possible spouse
that he could possibly get in
any set of stable marriages.
There's no set of
stable marriages
in which boy 5 gets a more
desirable girl than A. There's
no set of stable marriages in
which boy 1 gets a girl that's
more desirable to
him than girl E.
The sad news is that
it's simultaneously
pessimal for the girls.
That is, each girl is getting
their worst possible spouse
among all sets of
stable marriages.
We'll examine that
further in a minute.
But let me just point out that
this is more than a puzzle.
I mean, it's fun, and
it's a nice puzzle,
but it's more than a puzzle.
Because the original case where
it was studied or published
first was in a paper by
Gale and Shapley in 1962.
You may remember the name
David Gale from the subset game
that we played early in
the term when we were
practicing with set relations.
And what they were dealing
was with the problem
of college admissions
where students
have rankings of colleges
that they've applied to
and their preferences
and colleges have
rankings of students that
have applied to them.
And we're trying to get matching
up between college offers
and student preferences.
And in a circumstance
where a college made
an offer and a student sort
of accepted, but then later
the student got another offer
from a place they preferred
more, and they were
changing their mind,
and withdrawing
acceptances and so on,
it was making everybody
crazy, the administrators
and the students themselves.
And the desire was,
let's get some stable set
of offers on the table.
And Gale and Shapley
proposed a protocol
to get stable
marriages that would
apply to college admissions.
It turns out,
interestingly enough,
that although Gale and
Shapley are credited
with the stable
marriage solution
that we're going
to discuss, they
did that because they were
the first to publish it.
But, in fact, it had
been discovered and put
into practice at
least 20 years earlier
by a national board whose
job was to match interns
in hospitals, that is
graduating medical students who
were about to start their
further clinical training
as interns, now called
residents in modern language,
had to be matched
up with hospitals.
And the residents had
preferred hospitals
that they'd like to go
to, and the hospitals
had rankings of residents
that met their criteria.
And again, the issue was,
how do you assign residents
to hospitals in a stable way?
Before they had discovered
this stability algorithm,
it was a mess.
Again, there's a wonderful
story in the book by Gusfield
and Irving that is an entire
book about the stable marriage
problem published by MIT
Press, I think in '89.
And as a matter of
fact, I was the editor
of the series in
which it appears.
This stable marriage
problem turns out
to have a lot of structure.
And they describe a wonderful
anecdote in their preface
about the problems
that were happening
between the hospitals
and the residents
and the measures that were taken
to try to achieve stability
before they discovered
this algorithm.
Another genuine computer
science application
is one that was described
by Tom Leighton who
was a co-author of the text
and then now the CEO of Akamai,
an internet infrastructure
plumbing company that
has some large
number of servers,
I think 65,000 servers
in 2010 around the world.
And it basically is
providing cached web pages
so that they can respond
more quickly to local calls.
They have a problem
that they get something
like 62,000, 65,000
servers and they
get I think 200 billion
web requests a day.
So the web requests
are kind of acting
like the boys and
the servers are
kind of acting like the
girls, or the hospitals
and the residents.
And the web requests
have preferences
based on proximity
and speed of server,
and the servers have preference
based on where they're located
and the magnitude of the web
request that they're coming to.
And the question is, how do you
assign web requests to servers
so that things get
done expeditiously?
And it turns out that
the stable marriage
method gave a satisfactory
way to accomplish
that kind of matching.
And in particular,
because there's such
large numbers involved that the
stable marriage ritual, which
we'll describe shortly,
is very amenable to being
run in parallel.
Another application, it
turns out, to come up
was in matching
dance partners when
I was teaching this course ten
years ago with a co-instructor
who was a member of
the Indian dance team.
She said, we could use
this, because it turns out
that, again, there are boy and
girl partners in the dance,
and it was constantly the
case that one boy would
like another boy's partner
better, and vice versa.
And they would start
pairing up and leaving
the other people hanging
and there were bad feelings,
and it was a source of
disruption in the society.
There's a picture of
that Indian dance group.
My co-instructor's
not actually there,
but it gives you some
sense of the reality
of the problem here at MIT.
And she told me
that it was actually
being used by that group.